today I I think the thought there's
various things that we should go through
but I think the first one is data
structures and so I want to start out
with a discussion of data structures for
problem three so as we mentioned week
ago the the network is a is what
compiler writers call a dag directed
acyclic graph in which the in which the
elements are classified in the inputs
gates and outputs and the gates have two
inputs that have previously been
computed and you can write it in
straight line code as we did as we did
in the in the handout and the what the
first question is how do you want to
represent the dag inside them inside the
machine so what are the where are the
winning winning methods for this that
people have somebody want to speak don't
all speak at once and I just all smile
that's nice please on the offer using
this you're using list and that's the
data structure
I yourself put yourself into somebody's
preconceived idea of add a distraction I
data structure yeah each gate is it has
a symbol of its property list our number
of fields and party HP has a type of
that is also a great type like exclusive
or right or and it has a the property
list would say what like tight night and
what would it look if you look easy to
do it to do this one for example yeah
you would have you had three days one
hour I 15 inputs and the others are
inputs they fight jumpy the size of the
input
here we have a deal outputs
your wife put some parentheses in there
thurs lives but maybe they write first
without the parentheses now they must go
wrong under the property list and no
here you would get its up with sated
Kate yeah and then I went through the
whole thing that then gates it would
help XD you know what you're saying
where X is used and this is k0 right
this is Kate one right okay it seems you
know within it looks like almost looks
like garbage out garbage in and input I
0 a nylon right near the he'll be
provided access the inbox oneonta are
back and write a 0 i won
yeah where it is you can get through all
this with Hunter you real ok ok and
then and imagine there's the fields if
you want to put in there later ok so but
for values or something like that mm-hmm
ok is that what everybody uses so what
are the other ideas that people have
everybody's using this for this one no I
music see the hour you to see about it's
more acceptable to that or you have a
tight then you have two inputs an
analyst developers ok so you're keeping
with each one both inputs and outputs
even though they even though it's
redundant to keep these to keep the
outputs I mean you could always
calculate what the outputs are from by
looking at all the inputs but key to the
app but you'd have to look at every gate
to see you'd have to do it over and over
again yeah that's why I met we've done
it means that we've got extra things in
the data structure that aren't strictly
necessary as far as as having a
representation is concerned but if you
want to proficient on an FBI if you want
to you look at what you're going to be
doing with the day description you add
extra extra unnecessary redundancy as
they say the dilution of of unnecessary
redundancy division ok the helpful
redundancy oh ok now then but how do you
how do you decide what the names of the
gates are going to be the symbol of the
applicator soon as easy or hard for the
genomica come from Disney the gates are
numbered in the order
but in which they're generated and
they're generated by the procedural
framework just like the one you gave us
okay we're up some 3,000 some weather
run through in 15 states and good loser
well it's a basic there are three basic
procedures one which makes an and gate
one which makes an or gate one which
makes an xor gate and they're called in
the appropriate places in each of the
modules that it on your sheet and the
general replicates they take they take
two inputs and and they look at the
input might be like I zero and zero
might be another insult coming I mean
zero is what the masses are about are
somewhere in your data structures like
and then it doesn t initiative it
doesn't generate a gate it doesn't
generate a gate if the output is
predetermined yeah okay all right gnarly
yeah okay and then BTW generators then
go back and put themselves into the
output lists of beat of their interest
so and win this one one point cool if
you are a little generation procedure
that's a generate me an exclusive or
gate from 50 and I one which then
created this this part of the structure
and added g0 to the output list of I
survived 091 okay and then do you have a
list of all the gates to or something
like that huh then at the end I'm
wondering about two things one is there
is there a definite ordering of the
gates that that you can use later on
well in an algorithm it's awesome gate
is because before another Gator does not
make sense
the case since the gates are always
generated such that the inputs are
generated before the gate itself is
generated you know you have us you have
a kind of topological motor oil yeah
that's in any any acyclic network graph
there's a way to linearize it so that so
that the inputs are before they are
before the gaben and helpers acharya so
that if you take the gates in order with
the numbers think that you can do a
straight evaluation and how many do you
get all together when you do that
process I can't remember you guys I
remembered you get some somewhere in the
high for hundreds or something or
inventor uniform any days that you get
by eliminating 0 that was the high for
hundreds and then you eliminate gates
with dangling outputs I think you get
401 okay I got 417 I am members I rise
though okay yeah that's it is that right
well he also want to donate the ones
with which have the same input both from
left and right this was this happened
you got you had a I don't I just saw you
had it in the program okay so it's I
think I think I think I'll goes to
Avenger foreign 10 yeah foreign one ok
not I tried it by the way up on 32 by 32
more application and I got seventeen
hundred and forty seven gates before
removing the output once and then it
went down to 17 22 so this number 401
goes up to 17 22 when you double the
number of bit so you get a 30th parallel
32 by 32 x massari that's a 16 x 16 x
parallel 32 by 32 multiplied and i got
60 972 gates before
throwing them out when I was 69 33 at
the end so so the 69 33 again we're it's
going on it goes up by about factor for
as you can imagine none in the that's
just at the very beginning the very
first round is is the N squared right I
mean just to multiply all the xxi x YJ
is giving you the is giving you most of
the gates and that was depth 34 so you
could have a 32 by 32 parallel
multiplier with 64 bits of in about put
in 34 levels to logic with this with the
same construction and about a little
less than 7,000 gates altogether for
what it's worth now let's see we also
had this possibility that the gate might
be that there might be a gate has a
solid a zero output is that right there
Hannibal alright well do I guess there
seems to be one which each level of them
30 okay that yeah arms another gate
behind it which only feeds into that
game so you can't check pulse under this
gates victory hello now thanks for
saying that again so you say first of
all you for you've had three bits or
bitten and up to a judge here bits four
bits in five Fitzsimmons that after that
my program gives up okay it finds gates
and there was a gate that was solidly 0
okay so presumably on eight bits this
will happen also probably which means if
you try to detect all stuck at zero
folks which means that if we try to
detect all stuck at 0 false where we're
not going to be able to detect one of
them because they will if ya now what
was the other thing you said that this
gate your such as it stuck at 0 I mean
it's always 0 which one get this so easy
row but there seems to be another gate
which you can't detect the stuck-at 0
fault presumably
because it goes through the first gate
it's one of the inputs of being stuck at
zero me yo it's always really it's there
opera fellow oh that means them FC so it
has that I many races this is an and
gate a bitchin so there's some language
that that comes in here and it turns out
that it's always zero all right and not
of this one you saying that that I could
actually this one is used in its it's
used an exclusive or gate afterwards
some other stuff that kiddo she goes
nuttin order but ok what's the might be
different in the different ones brokers
or not take a look at these guys to
collect but I don't understand what you
said about the young like but I can
understand why this one would never be
stuck at like that at zero why do I
could never detect this constructor 0
because you did you do it comes of it
yeah that only feeds that gate ok so so
you say they're good for the game here
that comes here on me all right mmm such
that and there's no way of telling if
it's your one because you'll never
because if this guy talking about the
other while with the other one more lies
country should apparently to 200 so you
can't detect them Syria
resistor with me of the circuit are the
eighth Pole circular just of the small
case of what if I need have to check all
possible oh please nobody's done idea
okay so you're saying that if this one
has only one output then then there
would be then we'd be stuck because it
but because this one hasn't known yeah
it's taking anything that has to go
through this critical when you gettin
still detector stuck at one on that
upper gate business register okay well
let's uh let's see the one thing we
could do is is have a proof that it's
always do and then we move it from the
circuit there by having your gates right
but if first of all know which get it is
yeah okay so let me see what do you do
let me but I want to do this Democratic
which people think we should do say say
that we have 401 gates and and we detect
all the stuck-at faults that are of the
late hundred and two we detect all the
detectable ones but we assume that the
circuit is actually built that way so
that the gift is redundant redundant
calculations of a business the circuit
is still still supposed to do it as well
not one approach let me explain for
example just of us it is with a plus
coming in here now but we know that this
is 0 and this one this is some other
gate here I can still have a fault at
this exclusive or because this physics
expects our might still be stuck at run
the same as this one might still be
stuck at 1 or 0
and so so so that gate is actually there
and so we would have to detect the fall
for that one is one of the fall for this
one on the other hand there from there
they're sort of equipped I mean we're
just giving ourselves more chance for
fall and maybe if we if we were actually
designing circuits we would we would
have well while testing that would rock
while doing our theory of the circuit we
would realize that one of the gates is
redundant so we saved that we save two
days I mean save not on this one with
this flexible well yeah if they don't if
this one is meeting only two that you
could you could get rid of it too
because it doesn't have any mean if we
get rid of this one then there's no
outputs for this guy yeah he's not which
now no I I could I could tell the class
what the which gate this is and then you
could say go down if you're 99 instead
of 401 or you could leave it at 401 and
you know which would want kids right on
floor on I would know I was thinking
something else even a gate before it is
stuck at zero it's not fault in the
circuit I mean circuit will still work
properly so it's not as if so it's the
actual idea out of process yeah it's the
idea wasn't test the circuit see if it's
always going to work properly then it
doesn't matter if it's stuck at 0 so it
isn't really a fault okay so sense so so
we redefined the question saying just
through the circuit that find all the
false that is the value of 800
not only you dilated meaning to it well
if you're assuming that there's somebody
with only want to hear from Paul yeah
let me go case let me tell you what the
fact is because I happen to have a
circuit here let's see it identically
zero is the end of 7 21 and 7 18 7 21
and 7 18 they're both used into up in
two places so so the this situation does
not there it's another outlet for them
how are you look at the circuit before
it was looking at dangling Uncas I'm
looking at the search that for 401 gate
circuit in fact if I've done is exactly
my programs over the years I'd make one
or two bucks in like a gram security
spirit that they're exactly two gates
that you can be text editor in me three
and four and four and five kage yeah now
this is another case let me take me up
let me let me tell you it was a surprise
at first I look at this I said oh of
course this one's eyes going to be zero
and then and then I realized that it was
going to take me that if that that I
think it's a fairly up you know at one
or two page proof to show that that this
particular one could really different
gate than I thought what's happening is
that you got these these uh these
numbers a 1 through a 16 which are your
weight a lot of the initial partial
products a 1288 I guess it it's on or a
0 to 80 degrees erte so a 0 to a 7 are
the initial ones and then we think we
take a0 plus a1 plus a2 is equal to a 8
plus a 9 + and so on the last one will
being
a what is a day see I got written out
here day 18 plus a 19 was equal to a 15
plus a 16 plus a 17 and so we we started
out with eight inputs and then after six
of these are these reductions we have 22
left a 18 and a 19 well it turns out
that the that the bit that's zero is the
high road a bit of a 19 it just turned
out that that if you look at the at the
leading bits of a a very 15 8 16 and
eight seventeen i was getting 00 always
for a 15 and 0 1 so I zeal a bar is 0 X
bars for some X for a 16 and X 0 for a
17 and and and therefore a 19 which was
the which was adding this column and
deciding whether the whether or not
there were at least two ones in it was
guaranteed that the leading bit of a 19
which is the carry from from this column
it was always was always 0 and that's
the that's what it turned out to be well
now you have to look if this is a 15 if
i'm not mistaken i might have these
numbers wrong yeah I'm sorry this is a
13 oh no a 17 a 16 yeah i think it was i
think it's a 15 or 16 or 17 but mike my
proof might be slightly flaky but
something like that am I remembered
things that I went but but but based on
the the fact that these original inputs
are are known to be to come from
multiplication this is true it's not
going to be true if you start with any
any eight numbers
that a zeal is known to start out with
leading zeros in a seven is has 11 10
and turning zeros a six it had two
leading zeros and something I just but
in order to show that that that this
leading bit of a 19 was zero I believe
it's necessary to know that a six and a
seven are almost the same except shifted
left one or both of you a six and a
seven can either be 0 or crop or are the
same as the other one shifted over to
and by using all that fact and putting
it into the circuit it turn out that the
leading bit of a 19th could had to be
zero well this was now this just might
generalize to arbitrary length of
circuits but that's the funny one that
is that's the funny one that is zero and
and not miss oh so the facts are then
that we could simplify the circuit but
i'm not sure what you people would how
you like to to recast the problem yeah i
don't think that this in general would
be a valid way of doing things merely
because if an arbitrarily complex
circuit it might be something to be very
difficult to detect the fact in the
first place that a certain thing is not
going to matter in essentially that it's
always going to be at a certain value so
I mean the programs or whatever that are
doing the disc is you're trying to find
such a power should themselves be
capable of pointing out at least
pointing out which are the problem which
are the probable ones which cannot be
checked and then maybe one who check
them by the means oh I mean care you
have to essentially solve the problem of
questions whether you do it for four
after each I funny yeah that's me that's
what we can write I think we should all
be working on the same problem that's
why I want to get to an agreement among
you know we're going to take a vote and
we're gonna
to use majority rule on this so we're
all working the same problem now and
John's point is very well taken says all
we have to do is find a set of X's and
Y's so that if it multiplies these
correctly then it multiplies all X's and
Y's correctly in that that formulation
of the problem is independent of the
number of updates in the circuit there
might be lots of other gates in there
153 yes first is that what it is without
gluten from the mating zeroes what yeah
okay 753 I thought it was even
multiprocessing okay remember watch yeah
I never got that count because I
eliminate them enhancing print but ok
well there's a matter of when you come 0
goes to a I as a gate or not I guess it
isn't ok so so that's a that's one way
to state the problem otherwise we we
would say y'all reduce the circuit 22 a
simplified circuit and and then an
insult the problem on that one well how
many vote for the first alternative
leaving it at 401 gates we got one two
three four five six seven eight how many
booked for the second alternative
simplifying the circuit first and then
solving the reduced problem we got one
two three how many hours sleep the
presenters 823 and fall asleep
supplement the info of the Apes carry it
so we're going to go with the 401 gates
as it is and we just find a minimum
number of test cases that will it will
suffice to test whether or not it's it
can either correct multiplies everything
correctly or has more than one stuck at
fault assuming that stuck at faults are
the only kind of false Andy well but
then won't all the groups after on the
same here
brute force large program and kind of
drag Navajo down I mean is there a way
to do it other than brute force oh well
this particular through thought this
that this was always 0 0 could have been
could have been discovered by a
heuristic search I believe because I I
just I did it by by hand looking at this
this bit of a 19 and it required some
other bits in it it only went down about
eight levels and I could get it so it
wasn't necessary to go through I believe
I could do by hand this this thing on
the corresponding thing on a 32 by 32
circuit if I'm not volunteering to do
this but i but I think it could be
certainly done by Machine it wouldn't
require going through all through to the
64th combinations of 32 by 32 inputs 32
plus 32 inputs and to determine that a
corresponding gate in the in the larger
circuit is this is a constantly
constantly row alright the idea might be
to just have whatever she rustics you
use to check some proportion of the
inputs anyway sort of just indicate that
this is a possibility elected
possibility and then you check it from
there um yeah I have a thing that a
variety of methods is going to be useful
on this problem like I'm worried about
bringing Navajo down to I I mean there
are lots of ways to work on problems
like this that that will that will be
bad and I ended and I have tried some of
them personally
in fact I had this one this one
heuristic search that was using forward
and backward propagation as we had in
class so we could go in and it worked
fine it and on most of the gates and
announced on one of the gate sub I just
for fun I let it run until I shut it off
after an hour I mean it was it was sale
but just to see if it would ever you
know if it would ever converge in it it
didn't end up I I have a deal with mike
shinoda to see if any of his programs
can do can do services but on the other
hand other ones it did it they work it
worked amazingly fast and and in almost
most of them so so and it's all I turn
out that my that day that I defined the
way I want when I was exploring his
problem i had only three three days to
work on it but I work solid on those
three days then I the final solution I
came to was where the combination of our
methods no one method with use for the
whole for the whole problem maybe
somebody maybe you'll be able to find a
more universal I think well let me see
now so we've ordered then that was that
Vinny and the decision was to take it we
can all agree that we're working on the
same problem if we have these foreign
one gate Network and it's eat gets
easier to to agree on it so let's so
that's our that's the problem we'll
we'll look at has it has it has this
gate in it and and this end also the
escape even though neither one is
strictly necessary
okay now rich you said that erode and
see but it was equivalent to this well
if anything is equivalent is the same
patient structure where you have a node
in a graph for each gate which has
inputs and outputs which are pointers to
others no right let me show you one
other one other possibility just took
just two we did with a raise we can
imagine an array that's that that has a
has a the inputs are the numbers that
are less than or equal to some some
global variable a metate number of
inputs and then the gates are
represented here in the out so you know
this is input and gates and outputs and
then for each for each thing we could
have a type but a type field or an array
called techno where type of one would be
would be the code for an input and and
type ba let's suppose that well there's
many ways to do this but let me just
give one that that that generalizes to
sue compilers uh there's there's lots of
ways of doing it but here I would put up
one way is to give to you three three
words for every gate here where where
this one would say four five and six
this would really be gate number six
this one would be exclusive or this one
would say fetch and this one would say
fetch and then there would be a an
operand where this one says fetch one
and this one says fetch two
and then X or is the is the result then
let's see I'll do a couple more in show
so what what how this could could work
we have always every gate is a bunch of
fetches so if its inputs and then it's
up and then the operation fetch fetch
exclusive or again where this one
fetches seven is fetch one pitch to and
and then fetch a 10 is to fetch a which
is this six fetch Z which is three and
exclusive or now in these other fields
we can use that for for the list of
outputs and so so every gate and the XR
and an X or an input can have a field
here which points to the to the the
first use of the other thing so for
example variable one could point down
here to it where it's used in this fetch
instruction say 27 or other lands you
sign I guess and then this 7 could point
back to four there's an auxiliary of
pointing field let's say so if you
wanted to keep lists so that this Vista
Point 27 which could point to one point
back to four and then there's nothing
after that this is one way of
representing the list of the list of
outputs in in a simple link link fashion
when you compile this part of the
network it this was pointing to 40 but
then when you when you added this gate
you added this added this guy onto the
list and it referred back to the the
previous one the list could go in either
direction but probably pointing back is
just as easy now similarly this
exclusive or a would then be used in in
in 10 and 10 would point back to this
and the outputs would would all be
fetches and so everything that's used in
an output would would get moved here
that's what I haven't filled in all
these numbers but I think it's fairly
clear that that you could do it with
ordinary I it's in Fortran if you had to
buy by three arrays like this and then
you could have other other arrays for
value of our labels or whatever you else
you want to be calculating on the honest
thing as a goat now but that's not the
only data structure question in here if
we do in a heuristic search at least
maybe I'm maybe I'm naive but if I'm
going to do a search that goes forward
and backward as we as we did in class
last Tuesday I'm solving what are the
typical problems that I'm that I'm
working on let me go over here I have a
gate that maybe it's exclusive or gate
or something like this and I'm and I'm
saying that this this gate is I'm going
to assume that this gate is zero I want
to I want to find a values of the input
that's going to make this gate zero and
there will be several no properties of
other of other gates tunes so this one
is zero then what do I know about the
about the two the two gates that feed
into it that they're the same value so
this is somehow alpha and also that
means that if these two are equal and
and then suppose I have a arm and an or
gate here and there's some gate like
this I also have a value
let's see now let's let me make this a
one just so I don't don't need so many
so if it's a run then I know that this
is alpha and alpha bar that the two
inputs are whatever we don't know what
they are but whatever they are they're
different and similarly here at the and
gate if if this one is beta then this
one is going to be beta these two will
be are known to be equal because this
input is 1 to the N gate okay and when
you have a exclusive or gate if this was
an exclusive or instead of an end what
and this was known to be beta but would
this and this is is one we could Beit a
bar here on this time to think so it
looks like a the kinds of information
that we want to propagate if we want to
do an efficient problem-solving on this
thing would be first of all to know that
a gaze is known to be or assumed to be
constant and secondly that we would that
we would know assume some relationships
between different gates that these are
actually equivalent or in equivalent
values now the second according to
Genesis nobody has has put the second
kind of information into into their
analogous programs that they were that
they were using for with circuits but it
if you've got a lot of exclusive or is
it seems like like that's a big that
could be a big win the second kind of
information saying that that that we
have equivalence classes between between
things you don't know this beta might
might propagate along a long ways we
might have betas all over the place and
you might be able to combine them
somewhere else to say that data in beta
bar beta and beta bar is known to be
zero for example if you get two inputs
to an and gate one is paid and when it's
beta bar you know that the end is zero
even though you don't know what what
they do
okay so what what's a good way of
representing information that two values
or n values are are are related to each
other in this way does anybody have it a
good idea for that one everybody now I
don't even get smiles I know you have to
be any other day I got smart that's what
goes we all in you and we're not saying
you all know at the beginning with a
smile and now nobody knows and don't we
still not say you could have each value
on each line via function of some
certain set of variables ok this is that
a variable via another do you know if
conversion if conversion no yeah this is
what this is a technique used in
optimizing compiler yeah but to get rid
of conditionals if gift sounds like it
has to do with hands and arts like if x
and y and you know that x is false then
you don't Ryan you don't evaluate why it
unless you have to uh it does not to
deal with not evaluating the Y but it's
more like India flow analysis you know
if you're at some point midway down the
control flow graph of the program and
you've taken several if branches you
know that a bunch of conditions here to
be true that you follow down and in
choosing which what in representing the
condition of the data at that point in
the program it's like the intersection
of a bunch of different things and you
could represent them a logical called yo
this is it but there's a very special
case where we just we just have equals
and unequal why would I have run
formations and I say x1 is
hook x2 and then I say x3 is equal to X
4 bar and then I say x2 is equal to X 4
now what's the relation between X 1 and
X day so I have two variable equal ities
here and it's always with bars and non
bar now from this I can reduce the
relation between x1 and x3 because x1 is
equal to x2 is equal to X bar is equal x
3 button so so I want to quickly no x 1
is equal next three bucks but there's a
data structure that will tell me this
fairly what a quick opinions on you can
find yeah okay the Union find out rhythm
is a typical name for these for the
class for the keeping track of
equivalence classes where we add another
another feature to Union find where we
say where we have things are equivalent
but some of them are negated with
respect to the other and so what we
really have is up is an equivalence
class here x 1 x 2 x 4 x 3 x RX for some
how is it are known to be equivalent and
we want to be able to propagate across
the qualities quickly all right now
there are many there are many of our
ways to represent equivalence classes
and there's and the books have have a
variety of discussions of this and
there's one of them that I that I wanted
to activate I mentioned especially
because i think it's the easiest one to
undo you see if we're going to be going
if we're going to be exploring this this
circuit and we're going to be making
hypothesis where we have to have branch
it's it's sometimes desirable I get you
have to save the world so that if the
branch you took was was unsuccessful and
you have to try
again start over from scratch or you
have to have a way of undoing the
decisions that you made on doing what
what what changes the data structure you
made based on this assumption that later
proved to be false so on I want to show
you one that is a structure that as a
that's guaranteed to be if that's not to
be very efficient in practice and also
easy to undo for this for this problem
in and the idea is very simple if you
have if you have things that are that
are known to be equivalent to each other
let's suppose that represented by
circles you just have them point we just
have we just have each one point to the
next guy in the in the in the lid and
they also point and they also point to a
home to a to a on some eight a header
node also each one of these also has a
has a pointer to the header which I
won't throw out to the head but the
header here is is uh contains it it has
an address job that you can say that
without point a and the header says for
it's also tells it tells how many there
are in the ring the hitter i don't think
has i had a point to anybody in the ring
i think we can get by with only pointers
to the header then there's another one
over here that about say these people
are are also known to be equivalent and
they have their header with t plus three
so they're also 20 now bite let's forget
the complementing part of it first we
can represent the complement in part by
having an it the negative of the pointer
here for example or another bit in this
anyway some other bit in this represents
ain't saying that this is this is equal
to the complement of
of the other one if you don't have the
same bits but but now in order to in
order to make two things equivalent well
first of all it's easy to tell where the
two things are equivalent because
because you look at the pointer if they
point to the same header than the
equivalent if they don't point the same
header than they are okay and suppose
somebody gives you an equivalence which
is called the union or the univ and a
fine the fine is to find what
equivalence class here period that's
that's immediately but just you got 11
reference tells you what what equivalent
question is appointed to the header by
the union is to take two of these rings
that are not equivalent and to merge
them into one and what do we have to do
in order to make these two equivalent
well we got to change two rings into
wondering and we also have to update
some of these points okay now that's why
that's that that's where the the reason
for storing four and three comes along
in here we can look at those and see
which one is the smaller and use that
and choose to update the pointers in
this Marlin and so so by so suppose
somebody supported this is knows p and
this is q and somebody says now p is
equivalent to Q then let's forget about
the Q Bar would be another thing but but
there's a corresponding thing for Q Bar
ok now what changes have to have to go
in the data structure use another color
chart orange truck will be after what's
the smallest number of changes i can do
to this data structure to make the to
represent the fact that p is equal to q
nums re
one remember i'm given quite a su p NQ
and i don't know who points to pee I you
know I can I don't let me fool my back
to shop I mean you break the connection
at some point on any one of them let
some p they are a break that out out
connections connected to q connect it to
q can I mean connect it took you
remembering that the essentially
connected to the one next to cube
without doing that you is the first one
here well thank you for this one run all
right okay this one right I know what
that one is because he was pointing to
it I would I have appointed to that one
because few points to that one sir and
no you make Q point to the other one
next Sophie yeah um this noise is is
true by the way if you have two cycles
and you and you interchanged the
pointers you always merge the cycles
together this is a in a permutation if
you have two two disjoint cycles then
you multiply by a transportation that's
equivalent to changing to the point is
it so for now we got I a circle it comes
it's it's a funny thing but it does tie
everything together and it was immediate
to how did how to get that because we
just changed link interchange lake of
pee with link of cute that is
furthermore that we have to yeah so
first of all we got to modify these guys
bye-bye going around the loop to queue
in which case we could in fact figure
out if we wanted to who was pointing to
cute but while we were doing that so we
could have broken this this one in
another point and we also have to change
this to set by adding the tube
together okay why do you need the linked
list at all I mean what are you using it
I mean the circularly linked list too
yeah nobody all has allowed one does why
do we keep the man we just have clients
all the way up and its really been able
to change the header body yeah the
circle inkless is helping us to tell me
which which point us to change but good
party I just thought that instead of
swimming in each and each node a pointer
to the header the header itself could be
on let's say node which contains a value
again and if both of them are just
heathers which contain a value right you
just seen the value of the other header
and ya know that that leads to another
important class reunion find out rhythm
salute that growth that you keep on
going upward until you get to so that
the fine Tiger isn't searches and maybe
more than one step what you mean yeah
and those are stats are they're very
interesting theory of this it quick if
we could spend several weeks just
discussing unifying algorithms because
for example Targon has the has proved
that certain one has a has a worst case
that six you need more than the number
of things in the universe in order to
make it go more than length five things
like this and there's the nao and i have
proved that this particular kind of
scheme is is linear on the average that
is if you if you take equivalences on
the average then the average amount of
work per update is is something like 1.5
updates or something like this in the
worst case it's got to be n log n
because if you're always merging the
smaller into the larger it's known that
I mean it's not too hard to see that
that you couldn't be updating something
five times unless you list of the
the class has doubled itself five times
every time you you you merge how you get
into a larger one so anyway there's this
this one has a good worst case and also
good at end an optimum average case and
sense but but there are many other other
other schemes all right we'll the point
that I wanted to make is that that
undoing can also be because we still
have saved this number three still
exists and I think it's interesting to
observe that if I store the right
information about this i think i have to
keep only one or two things may come
maybe maybe I need to know p and q but
to make p in equivalent to Q again
suppose I wanted to undo this operation
let's see if we can figure out how we
could undo it so we're given the orange
and now we want to get back the yellow
so p is so so if i swap the point if
certainly if i swap the pointers of P
and Q again then that would delegate
that would give me my original two rings
don't have you old poop into
yeah i would keep I keep in a data
structure p and q saying that I one of
the things I did know is that I might I
would keep an undue data structure which
would have operations that I changed to
value so that would be setting up
setting p20 setting p21 setting p to q
20 p to q bar and then I would know how
to undo all floral of operations even if
you didn't you could still wander around
with the second ring until you came back
to the all right so you do a couple
hundred to the old hitter yeah somebody
has the numbers and gets doing it where
that one right away with your change you
could say that one of the things you did
was pee include 12 queuing and also
store the hitter okay so what if I start
this P in the Edit could I figure out
what Cuba no way around oh yeah I know
what seemed to that the header still
contains a number three is now ready to
dinner with that and so so it's three
steps when from from the beginning
that's that tells me what Q is because P
is pointing here and I can be changing
all these guys to point to the old
header and I'll find what cured and then
I can interchange the point of the P and
Q so so so remembering p and three on my
undo list would be a sufficient I too
can you have just missed over the order
to I think funny in that you have done
doing the order that you are you a
believer starter and backwards order
yeah so you have a stack but things
don't do and you go back that's a good
point if you try to go up the other
other way you'd be in trouble so undo in
last in first out order yeah okay now
there might be other it might be just as
easy to do undo other Union fine
structures and I have to add to this
thing extra complication of
negating bits and turned out that the
representation that I had
there might be other it might be just as
easy to do undo other union-find
structures and I have to add to this the
extra complication of negating bits and
turned up at the representation that I
had sometimes didn't restore this
structure exactly in it in the sense
that these these bits would either be
instead of instead of having like like
like stole I said that this was three
and this was three bar and this was
three bar you might have to i restored
it it might be that this is three bar
three and three I might have I think in
my data structure i might have reversed
the sense of an equivalence class but
that didn't I don't think that mattered
and I just I just changed all that
matters was the relation of things to
each other but not whether or not all of
these things if you complimented all of
the bits with representing I mean this
that if i change that one to this one
instead that would have a different
representation but its equivalent for
prop practicing purpose and I think
after undoing mine I didn't know the
difference between these two and i might
have restored this one at this one
something like that but it did but I
shouldn't matter yeah Mike troubles me a
sudden seemed to use this search
representation to represent all the
information that you get for instance if
you have an aura is output is 1 have you
expressed the relationship between
template
okay now if I have an author whose
output is 1 how do i represent take
represent the the thing of the inputs
and that's and it we haven't we haven't
got any information there we know if one
it's the one is one of the other is one
and it's an R and I haven't covered that
all right bye oven all that's output is
0 then we propagate we can push that
back to the inputs and we can push it
forward if you but there's some kinds of
feedback that we haven't haven't done
yet Anna that's a problem that I'd like
to leave until Thursday's has a very
interesting solution to of at least one
interesting solution but what time is it
not 201 we could we could talk about
that knowledge I wanted to finish any
other data structure issues than we see
so with somebody so one in one of the
points then that you could do i'm not i
don't mean to force this on anybody
under saying this is one way to
represent equivalence question i think
it's valuable to consider four kinds of
values and incidentally in this in this
case here if this particular
representation has happens to have the
property that on on an input on an input
or an exclusive or an these things that
have values the operand is a pointer to
where it's used and the ox ox field
hasn't been mentioned yet on the case of
a fetch the operand is a it says we're
to fetch it from the Ox auxiliary is the
next place where this input was was also
used so in other words you know in the
previous place where we're the same
we're the same value was fetched it is
here okay for the fetch but but then we
have we have the Ox field to use on
these other guys for values so you could
have
the value here of you know value of
values on the a in these particular
fields fetch we don't need values and
and here we could so here we have the
the value of the gate the known value of
the gate so far and the value of the
gate so far is a for three kinds it's
either known to be zero or known to be
one or known to be a member of an
equivalence class initially all the
gates are in an equivalence class of
size one they're known to be equivalent
to themselves you know and so so this
gives a you know this value for example
you could represent it the following way
0 could represent 01 could represent one
and the numbers 2 3 4 could be headers
and minus 2 could be could be the the
the negative of the of the header in
fact I believe what I did was I
represented 0 as minus 1 right so that
complimenting was always taking the
negative of a value so minus 1 we
represented a gate value of zero and one
representative gate of of one and then
minus three and three would be would be
values that are known to be negatives of
each other but minus three and four are
values that are uncorrelated with each
other and then then you could build
subroutines that would manipulate these
values and being able to undo the
manipulations on values now let's see
the the next thing to is to say what
kind of manipulations do we do on values
and that's to introduce what we would
talk up on Thursday so so
we had does it that there's several
problems to to work out one is to to
figure out what what what the whole goal
is of whatever whatever we're working on
at the time is we might be be trying for
example to well let's let's state the
following suppose we have up suppose I
have a my complicated dag and I I want
to find a set of inputs so that specific
gates are known to have certain values I
guess that's one reasonably general
subproblem so suppose I i want to say
thats a gate five is supposed to equal
one gauge six is supposed to equal zero
and gate 11 or let's say 300 is supposed
to equal one and now I want to find
inputs for and suppose I've decided that
this is a sub problem which I'm
interested in I'll find find a set of
inputs a general set of inputs for which
this lease have the property okay now
this is our starting our starting thing
and i'll end up it's very much like a
theorem proving problem in it too tied
in with other kinds of heuristic search
that is I want to I want to find I some
axioms which are values of initial
variables axioms x0 equals equals one
might be an axiom x2 equals x three
might be an axiom I want to find a set
of axioms from which these I theorems so
these are on these are unproven theorems
and I and I wish to to have a way of
verifying but because the exes are there
I want to have a way of verifying that
these are theorems and and thinking of
its theorem proving was is I think it
helpful
a very helpful way to look at because
you've got a sump you've got some things
that are that are known to be true and
some things that are assumed to be true
and some things that apply other things
but if they're but if you if you if you
mix up what's what's assumed and what's
known it can get very confusing and so
so there so there's a that's the issue
that I'm that I think everybody has to
confront for themselves to in order to
understand it it's you don't just all
right i don't know you got you don't
just understand it by by hearing about
it or seeing somebody else do it you
have to have to be confronting with that
yourself that's why i don't want to talk
much about it until you've actually had
a chance to think about well when we
when we do say that g 5 is 1 and g 6 and
0 one of the things we'll say suppose g5
is an and gate and it's one then we know
that both of the inputs to g5 have to be
one and so we're going to have to set as
a sub-goal to prove that the two inputs
are equal to 1 because g5 is one of our
goals now if g5 is but we could also
since g5 someday will be proved we could
also use use the fact that g 5 equals 1
I suppose g5 is the input to to an or
gate then we know that that or gate is
equal to 1 g5 is an input to an
exclusive or gate then we know that
we've got an equivalence relation on the
output of that exclusive or gate and the
negative of the input and and that will
be a consequence of what we are what we
will prove someday so a the general idea
is that that you can solve a problem
like this somehow or other manipulating
values saying saying that certain things
are forced to be true as a consequence
of things we've we've proved or or
someday will prove other things are
assumed to be true or sub goals are
still
are added to the list of things to prove
as we as we and but those those list of
things to prove are also represented by
values they prove that g5 is one that's
a one as a value prove that another sub
goal might be proved that g 3 is equal
to g 4 bar ok so now when you get to an
or gate and you say g620 and gee I'm
sorry g5 is one but that's an or gate
then you then you've got to sub goals
you can either you suppose its first
input is 1 or its second input is 1 and
so you've got a bike to bulletin and
let's say well let's let's first let's
temporarily assume the first one is one
and if that doesn't work out undo
everything backtrack and see if it's if
the first input is in and you know the
first input is 0 and the second is one
now that takes time because every time
you you split into two split your
problem in the two parts you might be
doubling the amount of time you spend on
solving the problem so it's about if
it's advantageous to do all the first
moves first to do all the all the
deductions that don't require branching
and carry out all consequences forward
and backward as far as you can that's
why an equivalent scheme like this gives
you a lot more things to propagate
without branching yet then there comes a
time when a branch has to be made and
there's a question as to which branch to
take and the are to end and to try to
minimize the amount of the amount of
branching that's done are the amount of
total amount of computation usually if
you put a lot of it it pays to put a lot
of extra computation into cutting down
the number of branches that you have to
do you know Andy some forward they'll be
backward chaining but couldn't you all
sees them forward chaining to kind of
reduce the search yes like forward
chaining for example you mean what for
instance to force a gate near the top of
the circuit you know a gate that's not
nested too deeply to be one or zero you
can explicitly can compute as we did it
a few sessions ago on which patterns of
them puts would force it to 0 or 1 so if
you've already forced some of the inputs
to be certain things and you get to gate
and you want to know if you can force it
you see if the currents that have been
put is compatible with the sediment
beside we force to get to be the server
the one so so so what I what I was
envisioning is that I have that that I
have a value structure here now in these
you need some with each gate every third
position in this section and and and
every position here those there are
values on these things and there's
relations between values whenever I know
that an n gauge is one then I know that
its inputs are both one whenever I know
that an XOR gate is one I know that its
inputs are both complements of each
other going the other way if an and gate
is 10 if it's if an input is 1 I know
something about the other about the the
value of it and if if two inputs are
complementary and I'm taking their end I
know that I know that the end is 0 it's
a complementary to ignore I know that
the or if it's also I know relationships
on these values and given any set of
values I can explore that to its
completion right it's a its closure all
of the all the consequences of any set
of values
in the value structure and I end up so
for example the as you mentioned the
input I might know that some inputs are
there well those'll those can propagate
forward all the way to to to say that
will know a lot of the other gates in
the circuit to incidentally there's a
wick but if I if I was studying with
this subproblem it might turn out that
in order to make these three true that I
need only ten percent of this day and
and it would be it would be a big waste
of time to be propagating inputs that
are never going to affect you 300 for
example to gates there so so I believe I
think I I started out by whenever I if I
was ever trying to solve a problem like
this i immediately sub setted my day
down to to the gates that we're really
really going to help me in since it
seems to be a much smaller circuit if I
if I didn't need the whole one the whole
circuit I didn't have to do forward
propagation into into things that we're
never going to be of interesting did you
pre compute that and some initial pass
that storms 830 knee all the things that
affect you later oh well we got that was
a diff you you taught me you can work
back from 300 all the things all the
things that you know so you could for
example that's how you have another
nother array for example in this
structure you can use course misfits on
I if you start out with a certain number
of gates that are that are marked saying
I know I want to use these we put a
check mark there well then you think
then you scan back and everyone that's
marked you mark its inputs and then at
the end you got everything marked that
that's relevant and so you don't
propagate forward to anything that's not
marked super soon I mean that it's like
garbage collection I guess
did you did you actually use this data
structure in the effortless yeah it
keeps just because that I write programs
in web nowadays they haven't made a web
version of other other and we put four
other languages here yet but this is a
this is the my current hobbyhorses is
programming in documentation as well as
has been alternating document
documentation with with code yeah you
want to see a example let's see logic
yeah remedy can you hold this up with a
guy we've only got two minutes left but
i want to show two things on the screen
and then we go on and then we'll go out
because this is just to give an example
of how of
okay this is a this is the way web
program looks it starts out there's some
documentation it's a 65 now we come to
the point a heuristic for choosing what
sub problem is so on function choose is
is described move up now run and he is
good okay that's that's longer than I
usually write in the web module usually
I try to go to about a dozen mines and
then these will usually refer to like it
says do complex calculation for output
ll 66 then you go to the 266 and it
explains what that means and it's I I
find it the fastest way to write
programs and get them get them going in
a hurry says this code is used in
section 65 and so I alternate
documentation with the program here's an
example of the out of the case that is
produces here we go trying to prove
values this is from the middle of a
proof trying to prove values that 8-11 a
17 level 0 that's the level 0 of
backtracking setting 559 true setting
661 true need to prove 559 need to prove
661 these are sub goals have to be
proved proved 811 that 559 and 661 are
true making 655 equal minus 568 that's
an equivalence operation need to prove
655 so on anyway at the end it said
proved this let's see at the bottom do
we actually come out branching on 599
something is true and it just just did
this did a long test and finally it said
okay so so finally I had a solution here
let's see this is that this is the
climax of this thing here you got power
your arms doing it again go up go up go
up go up here this is whoops no
higher that's it right here latest 2-1 1
1 1 minus 1 so
works this means i found a solution
either the 16 inputs this one is
equivalence class to it can be any value
this one is is a negative one plus one I
mean does not have to be zero has to be
one so that was a solution to the
problem that did it I never didn't need
to know x1 in this particular case okay
that's it that's an example of what of
what a program might look like if it put
out stream of consciousness at the end
just suggested to as an example of one
of one approach that's fine good okay
the and I didn't know exactly how to
handle discussions for this one too
because they're these many subtopics to
to do so i put these examples in here
just to get your mind thinking but
probably on thursday you something
you'll have a better way so we'll talk
about on thursday how you've done it
good see you then